bonjour à tous pour un nouveau de bouche
à oreille en compagnie de jean-luc
mauvais que ça va bien très bien patrice
c chronique oui c'est vous c'est
l'acronyme et de bouche à oreille voilà
on apprend beaucoup de chaussures voilà
ses ressources sur l'art de la table et
alors on va aborder un sujet
d'inquiétude intéressant qui est sûr je
n'ai pas surgelés c'est vrai que depuis
longtemps nous dit comme dirait jean
pierre coffe c'est de la merde
surgelés pas seul toit que lui même soit
revenue de sa baie alors est ce que
c'est si mauvais que ça le surgelé
pourquoi ça si mauvaise réputation
écouté patrice très objectivement moi je
fais ce métier depuis 40 ans et il y a
eu énormément de choses et de
contradiction avec les productions
jeun'est c'est vrai que quand j'ai
commencé dans ce métier les techniques
de dépannage et nationaux pathé
aujourd'hui on a des techniques qui sont
vraiment fantastiques nous avons même
nous est ici à une unité on appelle une
cellule de refroidissement qui est en
fait l'envers du micro c'était pour
réchauffer très rapidement il ya des
matériels maintenant qu'il fallait
refroidir très rapidement ce qui fait
que quand on a un produit frais de bonne
qualité sur le surge elle correctement
ils garent sega toutes ses qualités
mieux mieux que 6e même produit va faire
quelques voyage en camion en train ou en
bas on avait fait une enquête par
exemple sur les sur les haricots verts
et les plus frais solaire y convergent
surgelés parce qu'ils n'ont pas voyagé
que l'on se pose sur les marchés et
c'est très bon signe ne sais pas mais
également quand un produit s'est baladé
et il perd une grande partie de ses
qualités notamment d'ailleurs de ses
qualités organoleptiques de ces
vitamines et de ses parfums de son goût
voire parfois de sa couleur en plus et
il faut se dire je crois à nos amis
c'est que la france et prônant le pays
au monde et en europe qui aa les
contraintes de l'hygiène de sécurité
alimentaire les plus durs et c'est bien
normal d'ailleurs parce que c'est clair
que construisent nos barons pour la
chaîne du froid sûrement par hacker
chamba il vous dira encore que le
consommateur comprenne bien c'est pas
parce qu'un produit a été congelé aux
surgelés que c'est un mauvais produit
bien au contraire souvent bien donc on
vient de trotter maintenant il faut pas
non plus que les cartes deviennent
d'élections car
j'espère que non mais l'information des
consommateurs
donc voilà sachez que voilà c'est pas
parce qu'un produit surgelé que c'est un
produit bové tout dépend du produit à la
base ça la morale de l'histoire merci
beaucoup aujourd'hui que bozak a bientôt
matrix